>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
I-- how many of have been in the
seat since 10 o'clock this morning?
[ Laughter ]
>> Not bad.
I recognize several familiar
faces from when I was
up here three hours ago introducing
the wonderful Olga Grushen.
I have been reading Scott Turow for
as long as he has been publishing
and I don't believe I
reviewed his first book,
the wonderful nonfiction
account, One L, of his first year
at Harvard Law School
but I've reviewed many
of this novels invariably with
greatest admiration not merely
for their very considerable hours
entertainment but for their smarts,
their inherent and
essential seriousness,
the gracefulness of
their prose style.
Scott is a very useful exemplar
of how so-called popular
fiction can cross
into the areas supposedly occupied
by literature and achieve durable
and lasting moment of its own.
His new book published 25 years
after his first novel is
called Innocent and it is
in effect a sequel to his
first novel Presumed Innocent.
Both novels center on the
figure of Rusty Sabich
and the various extreme difficulties
he manages to get himself
into in the course of
practicing the law.
I should just say before stepping
off the stage that Scott writes
about the manners of the
court house and the law and in
that respect makes me think often
of another superb lawyer
turned novelist,
the late Louis Auchincloss.
Very different writers but both
of them people who continued
to practice law throughout
their writing careers
and to distinguish
themselves in both endeavors.
Scott?
[ Applause ]
>> Before it gets too far away,
I would you to make a brief
homage to Jonathan Yardley.
I'm not sure reviewers know this
but writers do review
reviewers [laughter]
and when they get together
and of course most
of the time, it's bitching.
Most of the time that I, you know,
they're sharing their complaints
about how unfair, so
and so, was to them.
But, you know, when you get to
Yardley, he's generally greeted
with a, well, you know,
Yardley is not bad.
[Laughter] And in point effect, he
is to me, as far as I am concerned,
the best book reviewer in the
United States among the people
who do this [applause]
on a regular basis.
[Applause] And my respect
for his reviews continues
notwithstanding the fact
that I'm not sure that
it's invariably praise
with what you've graded my novels
but I remember picking a book
out of a remainder bin in Arlington,
Massachusetts in 1976 while I was
in my first year of law school.
And it turned out to be Anne
Tyler's The Clock Winder
and I remember reading it
because even by then and I think--
Jonathan, you were writing
for a paper in South Carolina?
>> The Miami Herald.
>> You were at the Miami Herald.
And even by then I recognized his
name and knew that I regarded this
as a person whose opinions
about fiction I regarded
as trustworthy and sound.
And of course I was pretty snotty
young guy at that point having,
you know, just arrived from
the Stanford Writing Programs.
So, it is truly an
honor to be introduced
by Jonathan Yardley, America's best.
When I first encountered Jonathan
this morning, I was in a suit
and tie and 'cause the--
we were at a breakfast
where the attire wear was described
as business attire and Jonathan was
in shorts and a short-sleeved shirt
and I realized if Yardley can appear
in shorts and a short-sleeved
shirt, there's no reason I can't so.
And after several hours in my
suit I went back and changed
but it brought back to mind the
fact that I lived in Washington
for a summer in 1970 and at that
point, I had just finished college.
I had always wanted to be a writer
of fiction and I had started
to publish some short fiction and I
sent at his invitation a collection
of my stories to an
editor at the Viking Press.
And I actually went in to meet
him and of course for somebody
who long dreamed of
being a published author,
this was a very auspicious
occasion and this was in the days
of the 3 martini launches and
it was clear to me once I got
into this man's office that he
definitely had the 3 martinis.
And-- but he asked me what were
you gonna do for the summer?
And I told him, "Well, I'm going
to move to Washington and I worked
as it happens in the General
Services Administration,
in the press office there,"
and he looked at me and went,
"Washington, city on a swamp."
And of course once I got down
here and found that, you know,
it was hot but, you know, not
quite as unbearable as he thought.
I realized this was the,
you know, inevitable--
inevitable propensity of New
Yorkers to always believe
that life is worse elsewhere.
In point of fact, there's
probably no place
in the world hotter than Manhattan.
Once those buildings and streets,
all that concrete and, you know,
and brick and steel heats
up, you know, it's like--
it's really like walking around
in a [inaudible] but anyway.
Innocent, the book I am here to
talk about which was published
in May is the book that I said I
would never write and, you know,
Presumed Innocent was like
a lightning strike for me.
It-- I had spent many
years as I recount.
In 1970, I was somebody who wanted
to be a published author of fiction
and by the time 1986 rolled around,
I still never published a novel
despite many, many attempts
and then all of the sudden,
you know, this book came
out of it was bought by the
movies, a number of publishers
as it happened that chased after the
manuscript and the book, you know,
seemed to justify everybody's faith
and it performed wonderfully both
in the United States and around
the world and at that point,
the clamor began for a
sequel to Presumed Innocent.
And I swore in response
to that that, you know,
I was never gonna do that.
I would never write a sequel to
Presumed Innocent and I had a couple
of reasons for saying
that at that point.
One was that I really did not want
to try to compete with myself.
In its own small way, in its
own small place and time,
Presumed Innocent was kind of a
path breaking book in the sense
that it wrote about--
it talked about lawyers
in a slightly different
fashion than they've been talked
about in fiction before and,
you know, you can't step
in the same stream twice
and whatever was inventive
about that book couldn't
be invented a second time.
So I knew that the inevitable
comparisons would damn whatever
came next.
And more important to me was that
I really did not want to box myself
in as an author and I know that-- I
knew that if I wrote another novel
about Rusty Sabich and Rusty
Sabich's voice that, you know,
I would be a sort of tieing myself
to that for all eternity and that
if I was going to try to do other
things as a writer and as a novelist
that I had to start doing them then.
And so, you know, I've
written a number of novels now.
All of them sat in the milieu of
the law but, you know, otherwise,
you know, different
in their approach.
Even though they're all set in, you
know, my fictional Kindle County
in the books and the whole orient
part and the last of those books
which was basically historical novel
called Ordinary Heroes set during
World War II came out in 2005.
And this was a book that drew
itself from stories of my father.
Some of them true,
some of them untrue.
But it had ended up being
an immensely personal book
and when I finished it, I found
myself somewhat stuck and I began
in that mood for reasons
that I couldn't really
understand thinking more
and more often about Rusty Sabich.
>> While I was on book
tour for Ordinary Heroes,
I wrote down a story idea and
I do this from time to time.
I have a file on my
computer which is, you know,
very ceremoniously titled story
ideas and I-- but I had this--
just this one-liner
that came to me and--
then the one-liner was a
man is sitting on a bed
in which the dead body
of a woman lies.
And I don't exactly know where
this image came from it was sort
of a dream, a dreamscape
of some kind.
There is a painting by Edward Hopper
called an Education in Philosophy
where a man is indeed
sitting on a bed
with a somewhat bereft expression
and behind him is the figure
of a sleeping woman
and there's certainly
in whatever way the painting
suggest that this is post coital
and so she's clearly not dead.
But somehow my imagination
transformed it in that way.
So I wrote down this one-liner
on a Post-it note and I went off
on my book tour for Ordinary Heroes.
I came back and as I
said I was kind of stuck
about what I was gonna
do next and Rusty Sabich
for whatever reason impart probably
because I'd always made him
forbidden fruit in a way
and that was the one thing
I was never gonna do.
I began to think about him again.
And at that point, I was
contacted by the New York Times
and The Times then
and for several years
to follow had begun
publishing serialized fiction
in the Sunday Magazine.
It ultimately proved I guess to
be an unsuccessful experiment
which was unfortunate because
it was the revival of a practice
that it certainly worked well in
other centuries and even today
in other parts of the world.
But they wanted me to write one
of these serialized novellas
and I had always had an idea about a
judge who could not make up his mind
about a case and oddly that sort of
fired my thoughts about Rusty Sabich
when I told The Times, "Well, I
think I've got an idea for something
that will fit your parameters."
And because I have always kept
track of my characters, as I said,
the novels are interrelated.
They're all set in Kindle County.
Characters tend to move from
the background to the foreground
and although there are
mountains of material
that hit the cutting
room floor, you know,
I tend to develop the back
stories not only of characters
in the book I'm writing but
sometimes in the character on the--
of the characters who
have appeared before.
And for example, Rusty
Sabich had appeared
in the first draft of
the Burden of Proof.
Sandy's-- Burden of Proof is
about Rusty's defense lawyer
and Presumed Innocent's Sandy Stern.
And Sandy Stern has lost his wife
at the beginning of the novel
and remarries at the
end and the judge
who performed the wedding ceremony
at the end of the Burden of Proof
in the first draft turns out to
be Judge Rusty Sabich who has gone
on the bench after his time as the
acting prosecutor in Kindle County.
And my editor and my then
publisher Raj Strauss [phonetic]
who ironically I just bumped
into on the street in front
of a hotel in which I'm staying.
Raj looked at me and says,
this is too Jane Austen.
You can't do that.
And so it was cut but I knew Rusty
Sabich was on the bench and then
in the course of writing
Personal Injuries,
many years later there
was discussion and wonder
about the Appellate Court.
I knew that Rusty Sabich was the
Chief Judge of the Appellate Court.
And I called up my agent,
Gail Hochman, and I was just
in the early stages of noodling
around about this novella and I said
to Gail, I said, "You know,
I'm not committed to this."
I said, "But what would you think--
what would you think if this judge
who can't decide a
case is Rusty Sabich?"
There was this long silence at
the end of the phone and she said,
"You've been telling me for 20
years you're not gonna write a novel
about Rusty Sabich again
and now you're gonna do this
in a novella that's gonna
be published, you know,
serially in the New York Times?"
And, you know, and she was--
she's never been the kind of agent
who would tell me what
to do but I said,
"I take it you don't
think that's a good idea."
And she really-- her main
objection was if you're gonna write
about Rusty Sabich again, it's got
to be on a less restricted venue
so that you can write about
him with sort of equal dignity
to what you've written before.
And I recognized that that was a
good point and I put down the phone
and I looked at the Post-it note.
And I realized that it was
Rusty Sabich who was the man
who was sitting on the bed.
And if that was the case,
then of course the most
important decision was well then
who is the woman?
And it did not take
me long to conclude
that the woman would be Rusty's wife
from Presumed Innocent, Barbara,
and for those of you who have read
Presumed Innocent or seen the movie,
I think you would sort of understand
that I regarded it as sort
of just beginning that Barbara
would begin the next book dead.
But the question then of course
is well, how did she die?
And even more significantly,
what in the world are they doing
in a bed together 'cause
I knew it was gonna be
in real time, 22 years later.
And you know, and I first thought
it was some kind of amorous reunion
and then I went back and re-read
the end of Presumed Innocent
and at the end of Presumed
Innocent, Rusty Sabich says that he
and Barbara "a sort of half-assed
way" have become reconciled
that they had already begun resuming
their marriage and so I said
to myself, "God, is it really
possible that they stay married?"
And suddenly I loved the idea.
I knew exactly what I was
gonna be writing about which
in a few words is how some people
keep making the same mistakes
in their lives and, you know,
and why they that happens
at a deeper level.
So I think what I'll do is
I'm going to show you briefly
by reading what became of my little
Post-it note and then I will stop
and let the rest of the time
be occupied by your questions.
So give me one second
to grab the book.
[ Pause ]
>> This is the prologue to
Innocent as the sequel is named,
and it is told in the voice of
Rusty and Barbara's son, Nathaniel,
called of course in older age Nat.
A man is sitting on a bed.
He is my father.
The body of a woman
is beneath the covers.
She was my mother.
This is not really where the
story starts or how it ends
but it is the moment my mind returns
to the way I always see them.
According to what my father will
soon tell me, he's been there
in that room for nearly 23 hours,
except for bathroom breaks.
Yesterday, he awoke, as he does
most weekdays, at half past six
and could see the mortal change
as soon as he glanced back
at my mother, just as his
feet had found his sleepers.
He rocked her shoulder,
touched her lips.
He pumped the heel of his palm
against her sternum a few times,
but her skin was cool as clay.
Her limbs were already moving
in a piece, like a mannequin's.
He will tell me he sat then,
in a chair across from her.
He never cried.
He thought, he will say.
He does not know how long, except
that the sun had moved all the way
across the room when
he finally stood again
and began to tidy obsessively.
He will say he put the three
or four books she was always
reading back on the shelf.
He hung up the clothes she had
a habit of piling on the chaise
in front of her dressing mirror
then made the bed around her,
pulling the sheets tight,
folding the spread down evenly,
before laying her hands
out like a doll's
on the satin binding of the blanket.
He threw out two of the flowers
that had wilted in the vase
on her night table and
straightened the papers
and magazines on her desk.
>> He will tell me he called
no one, not even the paramedics
because he was certain she was dead,
and he sent only a one-line e-mail
to his assistant to say
he would not be at work.
He did not answer the phone,
although it rang several times.
Almost an entire day would have
passed before he realizes he must
contact me.
But how can she be dead?
I will ask.
She was fine two nights
ago when we were together.
After a freighted second,
I will tell my father,
"She didn't kill herself."
No, he will agree at once.
She wasn't in that kind of mood.
It was her heart, he will say then.
And it had to be her heart
and her blood pressure.
Your grandfather died the same way.
Are you going to call the police?
I will ask.
The police?
He will say after a time.
Why would I call the police?
Well, Christ, Dad.
You're a judge.
Isn't that what you do
when someone dies suddenly?
I was crying by now.
I didn't know when I had started.
I was going to phone the
funeral home, he will tell me,
but I realized you might want
to see her before I did that.
Well, shit, well, yes,
I want to see her.
As it happens, the funeral home will
tell us to call our family doctor,
and he in turn will summon the
coroner, who will send the police.
It will become a long morning, and
then a longer afternoon with dozens
of people moving in
and out of the house.
The coroner will not
arrive for nearly six hours.
He will be alone with my mom's body
for only a minute before asking my
dad's permission to make an index
of all the medications she took.
An hour later, I will
pass my parents' bathroom
and see a cop standing slack-jawed
before the open medicine cabinet,
a pen and pad in hand.
Jesus, he will declare.
Bipolar disorder, I will tell
him when he finally notices me.
She had to take a lot of pills.
In time, he will simply sweep
the shelves clean and go off
with a garbage bag
containing all the bottles.
In the meanwhile, every so often
another police officer will arrive
and ask my father about
what happened.
He tells the story again and
again, always the same way.
What was there to think
about all that time?
One cop will say.
My dad can have a hard
way with his blue eyes.
Something he probably learned from
his own father, a man he despised.
Officer, are you married?
I am, Judge.
Then you know what there
was to think about.
Life, he will answer.
Marriage. Her.
The police will make him go
through his account three
or four more times-- how
he sat there and why.
His response will never vary.
He will answer every question
in his usual contained manner,
the stolid man of law who looks
out on life as an endless sea.
He will tell them how
he moved each item.
He will tell them where
he spent each hour.
But he will not tell
anybody about the girl.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Hi.
>> I ask this question not
because of what happened recently
in the news but when I read the
book-- or I listened to the book.
It seemed like there was
only one line or one phrase
that mentioned capital punishment
and I copied that down and had it
on a Post-it note for months and
months and months and of course,
now I can't find it and
quote it back to you.
Would you comment on
capital punishment
as an attorney, as an author?
>> Well, you know, I have
commented extensively
on capital punishment before.
My friend, David Remnick, is here
speaking now or soon to speak
and years ago, I did an article
for David in the New Yorker
about my evolving feelings
about capital punishment
and I basically went from a
prosecutor who was willing to live
with it to a defense
lawyer and then a member
of the Death Penalty
Commission in Illinois
who just simply couldn't make
any sense of it and who felt
that the death penalty basically
rests on a faulty premise
that we can kind of create moral
order out of something that is bound
to function so haphazardly.
And ultimately, I turned that essay
or lengthened it and turned it
into a book called Ultimate
Punishment but in a few short words,
I thought that my own mistake
about capital punishment
and the reason I was long
ambivalent about it was
that I realized every now and
then that there were cases
like mass murders such as John
Wayne Gacy in Illinois who--
for whom what I regarded
as a coherent argument
could be made for execution.
And in time, as I worked inside
the Capital Punishment System
as a lawyer and eventually
on this Reformed Commission,
I realized that was
the wrong question.
The question we should be asking
is can we ever device a capital
punishment system that reaches
those supposedly right cases
without also sweeping
in the wrong cases?
Cases of people who are innocent
and I believe it's inevitable.
Cases of people whose crimes while
awful do not reach the same level
of moral gravity as others
who get death sentenced
and these other people get
death sentenced as well.
And after years of
thinking about this,
I conclude that the answer
to that question is no.
The law just simply
cannot sift that fine.
And if we have a death penalty
then we have to be content to say
that every now and then the
innocent will be sentenced
to death far more often that
that we will sentence people
to death whose punishment
in no relative sentence
has any equality to it.
And for that reason, I became an
opponent of capital punishment
and I remain an opponent
of capital punishment.
Nothing has changed my mind.
[ Applause ]
>> Sir?
>> Your first book One L, you
write about your experience
with the Harvard Law School
generally finding it very
anxiety-ridden, competitive,
and not much fun.
After 33 years, have you done
any rethinking of it to help me
after 51 years maybe to
reformulate my thoughts?
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, it's-- it's a timely
question for me because One L is
about to be re-issued by its
original paperback publisher
after a long happy life
in the Hatchet family.
It's now going back to
_____ 0:27:25 Penguin
and I've done a new
afterwork for the book.
And I confess there that legal
education at least to my eye based
in small part on the experience
of my own daughter who was--
who went through law
school at Michigan
and didn't have a severe a
time as I did, but mostly based
on frequent visits back
to Harvard Law School.
I think Elena Kagan who I hope and
expect to become a great justice
of the Supreme Court but she
also instituted a lot of reforms
at Harvard Law School and I
made it a much more reasonable
and humane place.
So I don't think I'd have
exactly the same experiences
but that being said most of--
One L is basically the diary of
an abashed neurotic [laughter]
and it has-- I think part of its
long life is that it has served
as an enduring assurance
to law students everywhere
that at least one person
went through the first year
of law school feeling crazier
than they do and so and it--
I suppose it will always,
you know, stand for that.
>> I would say it was a dead heap.
The dean at the orientation session
the first thing he said is there are
no glee clubs here.
That would have been a great
title maybe, better than One L.
[ Laughter ]
>> Thank you.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Two quick questions.
How did you come up with the
idea of the timeline in front
of the chapters because I wish
every book that moved back
and forth had that, it just made
it so much easier to pick to follow
and secondly, will there be
a sequel, sequel to Innocent
because I don't think
Nat's relationship
with I'll say the girl
can remain that way
with the secret hanging
over their heads?
>> Well as to the second question,
I really have learned
never to say never.
Oddly, it's more Rusty
than Nat and Anna
that interest me right
now but who knows.
The timeline was my
idea and my editor
at Grand Central, Deb
Futter, hated it.
And she kept striking it out
as I submitted different drafts
of the manuscript.
For those of you who that
haven't read the novel,
it does indeed go back
and forth in time.
It starts as it does
with Barbara's death
and then goes backwards
to the year before that.
And I just thought, you know,
let's help the reader our here
to understand where
this novel is going.
And Deb didn't like it and I get
e-mails every week from readers
who say what a wonderful idea and
I, of course, since, you know,
since I'm a snotty little guy,
I forward all of them to Deb.
Yes, sir.
>> Hi. Can you talk a little bit
about how you write as far as,
you know, do you use an outline.
You know, when do you
have a draft complete?
How much rewriting do you do
and just any other approaches
that you found that served you well?
>> I really resumed my career as
a writer of fiction after I got
out of law school by writing on
the morning commuter train and at
that point in time, I had only
like 20-30 minutes a day to write
and I found that you don't
have any time to warm
up when it's 20 or 30 minutes.
So I just wrote whatever had come
to mind the prior day as something
that I thought might
be good in the novel.
And it didn't matter where
it was in the story line.
I just wrote it down whether
it's a snatch of dialogue,
a character description, a
piece of character history.
It didn't matter.
And the fact is I still
write that way.
For about a year, I let
myself kind of wander
around in a book allowing the
characters to sort of, you know,
create slowly overtime, their
situations, to spell themselves out,
like just talking about Innocent.
If Rusty and Barbara were still
married then one of the stuff,
the kinds of things I would write
originally would be, you know,
well what are the terms of this
marriage trying to imagine it
and you know, that's
where the conclusion came.
Well she had to have been--
she had to have been diagnosed
with a diagnosable mental
disorder that's part
of the reason that
he stayed with her.
And that's the kind of thing I mean
about feeling my way along and--
but there's no particular order and
then after a year, I write a draft
and I show that to agents
and family and editor.
And, you know, I go from there.
There are usually about
four to five drafts so.
That's the-- that's
the long way I process.
I'd never outlined.
I could probably write
much more quickly
if I force myself to outline.
The one exception is Limitations
that little novella I did
for the Times and as much as
I like things in Limitations,
I would have loved
to have had more time
and a little more chaos
in my own head.
So I went right back
to my standard way
of operating after I finished it.
Thank you.
How are we doing on time?
I have a little time left, I'm told.
Sir?
>> Yeah, I like the timeline a lot.
I didn't read Presumed Innocent.
By the way, I came to your novels
by a lawyer friend of mine,
who is very literary who
said you're much better
than John Grisham, so [laughter].
This may be too sillly--
>> You may want to pick that
microphone up a little bit
so that you're speaking-- You may
wanna repeat your prior remark.
[ Laughter ]
>> Anyway, I don't know.
I wouldn't describe it as a flaw but
having not read Presumed Innocent,
Barbara comes out as a sympathetic
character to me in most of the novel
and in the end, she just comes
off as a prescription drug addict.
You know, her-- for those who
didn't read it, her husband
and her son have sex-- had an
affair with the same woman.
>> Well, let's not tell too much to
the people here who haven't read it.
There's gonna be a question
at the end of this though.
>> If my perception
is right then she kind
of got what she deserves
she was just [inaudible].
Or maybe do we have
to read the book.
>> Well, I have to say that, you
know, I never say what the ending
of Presumed Innocent was in
Innocent because it turns
out there's another generation
of readers who haven't--
don't have the same kind of level of
familiarity with Presumed Innocent.
I've been delighted by the number
who have read Innocent first
and gone back to Presumed
Innocent but I thought
without elaborating too much on this
that one of the things I felt best
about was that by the time I
reached the end of Innocent,
I actually felt some
sympathy for Barbara
and found considerable nobility
in her at the end of the book.
You know, people can make up their
own lines for themselves but anyway,
I appreciate the question.
Thank you.
>> Hi. Earlier, you were speaking
about a judge who can't make
up his mind so I guess my question
is in the lives of your characters,
you're judge, jury,
bailiff, god in that way.
I'm a new fan, just finished reading
Pleading Guilty and I'm wondering
without talking about the ending,
how you came to that
particular ending
and did you entertain different
ideas, different things--
>> The ending of Pleading
Guilty, you are trying to mean?
Yeah. Yeah.
I entertained different ideas.
You know, the story
of Pleading Guilty is
that after I finished
the Burden of Proof,
I began the novel that's now
called the Laws of Our Fathers
and I was a great reader of Norman
Mailer especially his nonfiction
and one of the remarks
he makes in Cannibals
and Christians is the terrible
thing about being a novelist is
that you can make a drastic mistake
and not discover that
for six months.
And in the course of writing my way
along in the Laws of Our Fathers,
I made that kind of mistake.
I did something in terms of plot
that was just never ever gonna work
and so I stopped and
to amuse myself,
I decided I'd write this story about
this kind of broken down former cop,
a fish out of water,
in a big law firm.
And principally as a way to
sort of share my ironic view
of what was going on in the
practice of law and, you know,
I find Mack Malloy to
be a tremendous wise guy
but as always happens
with me once I get
to know the character then I decide
that something serious is going on.
And obviously the end
of Pleading Guilty
and we won't give it away is
pretty gloomy but I thought
that I did think it fit the novel.
I thought all in all
this was not a situation
that was ever intended
for happy endings.
So-- We have time for one more.
We're in overtime.
Alright, last question.
Go. I'll be-- You'll be
quick and I'll be quick.
>> Okay. Scott, can you tell us
about how the effects of the economy
and recession have had on the legal
profession, changes in compensation
from billable hours to
flat rate [laughter]?
How does that change how
you depict your characters
so for the 20 years you've
been writing about law?
>> You know, I don't know yet
because I haven't had a chance
to write about the
contemporary legal environment.
There's a little bit of reference
to it and in Innocent where one
of the characters is working as
an associate in big law firms says
that she suddenly sees her
future as being, you know,
one where she was gonna get
all her litigation experience
in bankruptcy court.
Lawyers in a strata have had it
very, very good in this county
for several decades and you know,
it's hard at this point to believe
that it's ever gonna quite
go back to what it was.
Those kinds of predictions though
inevitably end up proving false
but I know a lot of people
in the profession don't quite see
it coming back in the same way
but I will say to you
what was said to me
when I began the practice of law.
Clients will always
find a good lawyer.
It will always happen.
One of the great, great things
about the practice of law is
that in its own way, it's
extraordinarily meritocratic
and good lawyers who work
hard and who are dedicated
to their clients tend to
be rewarded in that system.
So, with that closing piece
of advice, I thank everybody
who attended the book
fair for being here today.
Thank you very much.
This is a wonderful event.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.